this video was made possible by class
central.com
/ Pakman which lets you watch tens of
thousands of lectures from the world's
best universities check it out by
clicking the link underneath this video
next up in the pseudoscience miniseries
faith healing the practice of using
prayer or religious rituals to improve
the health of oneself or of another
faith healing is sometimes used in
addition to medical treatments which can
be harmless faith healing is sometimes
used instead of medical treatment which
can be really dangerous and in some
cases deadly some studies claim that
prayer can create a placebo effect or
improve the morale of a patient but no
data points to faith healings efficacy
as a means of supernaturally affecting
health outcomes regardless laws in the
US are pretty accommodating to people
who want to bypass medicine and instead
choose prayer 49 US states allow
religious exemptions for vaccine
mandates 31 US states exempt parents
from child abuse charges
when child medical treatment is withheld
on the basis of religious belief meaning
that in most US states if a child is
sick and their parents refused to allow
medical treatment because they prefer
faith healing no one can be charged with
child abuse or neglect if the child gets
sicker in six of those states Arkansas
Idaho Iowa Louisiana Ohio and West
Virginia those exemptions actually
extend to homicide if a child dies
because their parents wanted to pray
instead of seeking medical treatment the
parents can end up getting off without
any punishment some people justify this
with First Amendment claims about
religious freedom but it's also a
reflection of the United States being
one of the most religious countries in
the developed world as of 2018 80
percent of Americans say they believe in
a literal God and an additional ten
percent say they believe in a quote
spiritual force and multiple recent
surveys find that two-thirds to
three-quarters of Americans
leave prayer has the ability to cure
diseases the government and private
sector have spent millions of dollars
studying the efficacy of faith healing
over the last several decades there's a
1997 study by the University of New
Mexico which found that individuals
praying for patients recovering from
alcohol dependency had no effect on the
patient's outcomes a 2000 study
published in the annals of internal
medicine found no connection between
prayer and health outcomes for patients
with any medical conditions a study from
99 to 2002 by 8 medical institutions
including Duke University Medical Center
involving 748 patients concluded that
quote prayer did not have a significant
effect upon the primary clinical
outcomes and a 2006 meta study published
in the annals of behavioral medicine in
oh six concluded quote there is no
scientifically discernible effect for
prayer as assessed in controlled studies
given that the prayer literature lacks a
theoretical or theological base and has
failed to produce significant findings
in controlled trials we recommend that
further resources not be allocated to
this line of research there was a
decade-long study in the 2006 American
Heart Journal with 1,800 patients which
found that prayer had no effect on the
recovery of people undergoing heart
surgery a 2007 study by the medical
research firm Cochrane assess patients
with a broad range of health issues and
found that praying had no meaningful
effect on their outcomes there's a
number of small radical Christian
factions in the United States that deny
themselves medical treatment in favor of
Prayer the most notorious is Christian
science a religious movement founded in
the u.s. in the late 19th century and
today they've got about 100,000
adherents worldwide the Christian
Science church is known for ostracizing
people who seek medical care or parents
who allow medical treatment for their
kids and this can include everything
from vaccines to life-saving antibiotics
the Christian Science church regularly
tells sick and disabled children that
they are afflicted with health problems
because they
lack faith and moral purity and are even
known to say that children suffer
because their parents lack that faith
and moral purity by the mid twentieth
century it was easy for state and local
governments to prosecute and convict
parents for withholding medical
treatment from their children for
religious reasons but today most states
have laws allowing parents to deny their
children medical care on religious
grounds and how this happened is
interesting in 1967 a five-year-old girl
died of pneumonia she could have been
treated and saved by antibiotics but her
mom was a Christian Scientist who wanted
to use prayer the autopsy showed her
chest was filled with more than a quart
of pus which collapsed her right lung
and put pressure on her liver this is a
slow agonizing death
her mother was convicted of involuntary
manslaughter by Massachusetts sentenced
to five years probation without jail
time elders in the Christian Science
church saw this as a wake-up call and
lobbied the federal government for years
to allow child neglect and homicide
exemptions for parents who deny medical
treatment to their children for
religious reasons they didn't have much
success because America was becoming
more and more conscientious about
reporting and researching and
investigating child abuse and then in
1971 during the Nixon administration
future vice president and then
Democratic senator Walter Mondale
created the Senate Subcommittee on
Children and Youth
the mission was in part to further
advance child protection in the United
States by 1974 the subcommittee pushed
through one of Mondale's most important
accomplishments the child abuse
prevention and treatment Act which
legislated and provided federal funding
to States for investigation prosecution
and treatment of child abuse and neglect
the next year Nixon's chief of staff H R
Haldeman and chief adviser John
Ehrlichman were convicted and sentenced
to prison for perjury conspiracy and
obstruction of justice this was part of
the Watergate scandal
what else did these two convicted
criminals have in common they were both
Christian Scientists and during the
writing of Mondale's
child protection legislation
for they were imprisoned Haldeman and
Ehrlichman were pressured by the
Christian Science church to make sure
that the following clause was added to
the bill quote no parent or guardian who
in good faith is providing a child
treatment solely by spiritual means such
as prayer according to the tenets and
practices of a recognized church through
a duly accredited practitioner shall for
that reason alone be considered to have
neglected the child
this means that Haldeman and Ehrlichman
and the Christian Science church ensured
that no state would receive Mondale's
child protection funding unless they
made religious exemptions for denying
child medical treatment the Christian
Science church found a way to dodge
child abuse laws and as a result over
the next few years
49 states legalized the religious
medical neglect of children thirty-one
states still have these religious
exemptions and children regularly suffer
and die needlessly as a result under
most circumstances adults do and should
have every right to refuse medical
treatment for themselves but doing this
to children replacing medicine with
faith healing is a different story
altogether
a study published by the American
Academy of Pediatrics found that between
1975 and 1995 about 80% of children who
died after their parents withheld
medical treatment for religious reasons
would have had at least a 90 percent
chance of living if they had received
proper medical care we're talking about
hundreds of lives here faith healing
without a doubt should require proof of
its efficacy especially since the stakes
are so high and so far faith healing has
passed no meaningful tests and until it
does it should be clearly called
pseudoscience and really one of the most
problematic pseudo-sciences faith has a
long complicated history interacting
with science and if you want to delve
deeper into the relationships between
mythology and empiricism check out class
central.com slash Pakman and check out a
new online course from the University of
Alberta
called science and religion 101 plus
central offers tens of thousands of
university courses on virtually any
topic you can imagine start searching
for top-rated college lectures from
world renowned universities by clicking
the link under the video they have
classes on almost everything business
science math computer programming
politics economics you'll definitely
find something you love and a lot of
those courses are completely free check
it out at class central.com slash
Packman or just click the link in the
video description below